From November 1st to November 10th
we will experience the science path in our city this year,
but not
only
because of this special situation in which
we are all now due to
corona, this time it will be a new,
different 1 path
in virtual space  in the hybrid room there will
be over 200 different
options for discussions and encounters
via the digital possibilities,
everyone will have the chance to follow practically every
discussion in every forum
i can only invite you all to be part of
it be part of it
to experience this exciting format, especially in
these  times it becomes clear how important
science and research are how
important it is to exchange
information on a good path have fun have lots of
success and good insights into what
we will all
see and experience as part of this year's science path